j'ai su piéger dans son bureau les
journées sont interminables et je me
retrouve tout seul avec mon ennemi juré
numéro un un grand malade quatre
plaintes cette semaine cap ça sert point
final sur provient du maquereau la mer
il s'éteint est tout de suite si tu veux
pas que
vous avez fait mon travail un cauchemar
nous avons prévu de créer un poste de
directeur général lequel devra
superviser chaque département il est
pour moi ce travail cupcake qui décroche
le job je démissionne mais si ce témoin
en trente ans je ne suis pas capable de
te faire plaisir à ce point là tu dois
avoir l'habitude de parler comme ça aux
femmes non je peux me tromper mais on
dirait qu'il ya un petit truc entre vous
non
je les déteste stationné
look d'enfer c'est un bel honneur
guerre psychologique
je me demande ce que ça fait d'avoir un
pouvoir magnétique s'en servir comme une
arme je fais un rêve bizarre cette nuit
j'étais dans mon lit toute nue j'ai une
théorie
la cour jouent ce petit jeu puéril de
tous les jours et testé quelqu'un
revient bizarrement à tomber amoureux de
lui
je te propose un nouveau jeu le jeu de
la première fois moi j'ai aucune envie
de passer un examen en attendant que tu
fasses ton choix
[Musique]
on n'aura jamais confiance l'un dans
l'autre on est en train de se battre
pour occuper le même poste tu peux
croire c'est moi confiance
je t'avais dit qu'elle l'a cheval à
faire s'il pense que tu en poste pour
elle ce sera très facile de la mettre
hors jeu tu ferais n'importe quoi pour
décrocher ce poste de toute façon j ai
aucune envie de continuer
je comprends pas à quoi tu joues je
croyais que tu me haïssez c'est faux
alors on doit jouer à quoi maintenant
[Musique]
la première fois que vous avez dit josh
gad et vous pensez et j'ai trouvé qu'il
épiait froid est aussi terriblement
coincé j'ai trouvé que l'uci avait à
côté à ces lectures ont cédé tester au
premier regard